So tell us about this dish you're gonna teach us
from your upcoming book.
So this is in the winter chapter.
It's a wild mushroom bolognese with hand-cut pappardelle,
and we got it started already, so in this pot,
we have some bacon, we got some onions caramelizing
with a little bit of salt and some carrots,
and they're softened and ready to go,
and right now, we are ready
to add in some freshly minced garlic.
Uh-huh.
And then we're gonna add our mushrooms in.
We have some really nicely chopped portabella
and oyster mushrooms.
And the nice thing with this recipe
is you can use so many varieties
because they all have wonderful, unique flavors.
We're stirring this in
and the mushrooms are gonna cook down a bit.
They're gonna have more flavor
and a lot of the water is gonna get cooked off as well.
And then once these cook down,
we're gonna add some delicious...
Tomato paste.
Tomato paste, so-
You have umami on umami.
Yes, and like tomato paste is such a wonderful ingredient.
You really take all the nutrients,
all the flavor out of the tomato,
and just concentrate it with sunlight, you know?
And here we can add in like a nice pinch of salt.
So, here, everything's coated, it's smelling delicious.
Like I love these like just wonderful smells
and you have some choices for deglazing the pan
and adding some liquid back in.
This is where I get intimidated
but I do wanna call something out about your recipe
that I went through last night.
So, I get nervous when I hear deglaze the pan
and get the brown bits.
This is where my stomach churns
and I feel very inadequate in the kitchen.
Do I pour the whole thing in?
Yeah, you can pour the whole thing in.
We have two different pieces here.
Some studio magic happening here.
(Drew growls)
'Cause we have our simmered away, delicious,
look at the difference in color.
You could just see it really cooked down.
It's like a gravy.
Yes, oh my gosh.
Beautiful.
We also have some delicious hand-cut pasta
in front of us, and you can make it, you could buy it.
I think it's fun to make, so it's like a fun thing to do
with your kids too, but I understand time,
so go ahead and just...
Can I just ladle it in there
so that I kind of coat the noodles?
Yeah, we're gonna ladle some in
and coat the noodles just to give them a start.
Okay, this is, oh my god, this is so exciting.
(groans) I don't know why it's pasta for me.
It's just my very favorite food.
There's something about it that's so artistic,
so comforting, so incredibly expressive and diverse,
that can be so many things.
Yeah.
I...
Oh, you have the perfect twirl.
I do?
Yeah, I love this.
Here, I'm gonna bring it closer so you can just
pop this in.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, you know what's the best trick?
Yes.
Sorry, take your ladle.
Actually put it on there and then start to twirl.
You're also so brave for not using any apron in this.
I'm not using an apron.
Get on there, you get on there.
Beautiful.
I think it's nice.
(audience applauding)
So ladle some more of that sauce on and then-
I did ladle some sauce on, a little extra sauce on top.
Oh, you son of a,
sorry.
Then,
you could grab some delicious Parmesan
and just grate it on or-
A Parmigiano.
Yes.
Sprinkle it over.
You could add some more herbs, whatever you love.
Okay, cheers.
See, your portion's what I'd really eat.
Yeah, this is like a...
I was just trying to be fancy
and ladle my way into a perfect little thing.
This is so exciting.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it is so wintery and delicious.
Cozy, like hearty, it's like mm.
Absolutely roastingly delicious.
Tomatoey, mushroom-forward.
Oh my gosh, can you write the...
(audience applauding)
(Drew mumbling)
(John chuckling)
I also really wanna talk about how beautiful it is,
the way you speak,
and if we could all just be a little more gentle
with each other.
I'm sorry, it makes me emotional.
(chuckles) Come here.
(audience applauding)
People wanna learn, and they don't wanna learn
by that sort of fast-paced judgment.
They want a gentleness,
and that's what you're doing.
Oh, thank you.
And I so appreciate that.
You're doing it too.
This is, clearly you're a kindred spirit.
(audience applauding)
I'm not having nervous breakdown.
I really just appreciate your approach,
and I think it's a really masterful one.
Thank you.
And I-
Food is love.
Yes.
It's coming together, it's having dinner with your family,
your friends, and just taking a breath
and like putting your phone aside.
So, let's speak that language kindly and together.
Well, you speak it so beautifully.
Anyway, John Kanell, thank you so much
for this profound tutorial.
Thank you for having me, my gosh.
That really struck such a chord with me.
I'm so grateful.
Visit the drewbarrymoreshow.com and Cookbook Club
to check out John's pick for Cookbook Club for himself.
I can't wait to see what that is.
Will you tell us?
I will.
Okay, good.
Go to .com to find that out, and the "Preppy Kitchen:
Recipes for Seasonal and Simple Pleasures"
is available for pre-order and will be available October 4th
and we'll be right back.
(bright music)